mary kay cabot for a mary kay cabot from
the Cleveland Plain Dealer joining us in
Cleveland com joining us right here on
the Rich Eisen show how confident are
the Browns right now around that team
you know they're really confident and
I'll tell you what when you go out to
those practices you would never know
that you're looking at a 3 and 13 team
from last year there is a high-flying
offense I mean you have to think about
this to Jackson he knows offense right
and L Saunders his right-hand man you
know who is so involved in the greatest
show on turf and they are installing
that sort of done coryell high-powered
offense and this thing is moving like
lightning in practice and there are some
weapons on this team like you said it's
going to all come down to RG 3 can he
pull it together can you get himself up
off the mat I mean he was the third
string quarterback in Washington last
year in active all 16 games and
sometimes playing as a safety on the
scout chest well and there's no doubt
that he's going to be the guy why
haven't they just come out and named him
the starter what what what gives on that
whole front Mary Kay you know what I
think that that you really wanted to see
that rg3 could be all the other things
that he needs him to be the face of the
franchise and most importantly he wanted
to know that he could lead these players
the biggest problem that rg3 head in
Washington were you know he didn't win
over the locker room the players didn't
really like him he didn't know exactly
how to get everybody behind him and
rallying for half and you know that was
a number one thing he wanted to see
could he do that and you know he has
done that too huge satisfaction now in
large part was help from from Josh
McCown josh has really helped him figure
out you know how do you do this how do
you be one of the guys so to speak and I
mean rg3 has done so much in that regard
you organized you know bowling outings
she's hanging out with the guy she's
having you know Corey Coleman and others
work out with him in LA with Tom house
and he's just going overboard to show
you that he's that guy he's Josh Gordon
a different guy from the last time you
saw him you know I noticed in him a
little bit less than Niall a little bit
more really
to get help you know he just seems to
understand now that you know what maybe
I do have to change my lifestyle and
maybe I do actually have a problem he
never believes that before and so when
he comes back what do you think we're
going to see out of Josh Gordon well I
think he's going to have to knock off
the rust a little bit but josh has so
much law athletic ability you know I've
never really seen anything quite like it
where you can just you know step on to
an NFL field and do what he did early on
it for having not a whole lot of playing
time at Baylor because of the issues
that he had there he just has a knack
for for going out there for getting open
again this is an offense that is very
well suited to him similar to the one
that he was in when he led the NFL with
16 46 yards in 2013 so you know he's
back in that sort of aerial type of
scheme and as long as rg3 t getting the
ball and hey they've had some experience
together with this it should be pretty
exciting mary kay cabot of the Cleveland
Plain Dealer joining me here Isaiah
Crowell what he posted a few weeks ago
beyond unacceptable we can't there there
are no words for what he posted and then
took down is he redeemable in any way
shape or form in the Cleveland area Mary
care you know what I I do think so i
really do think so I mean I've gotten to
know him over the years and I know that
it was in the heat of the moment and
like you said inexcusable and no one can
make him say anything at all to get him
off the hook for what he posted it was
horrible but he deleted it right away
and he's taken great steps since then to
really try to atone for this horrible
mistake including attending the funeral
of a slain Dallas officer of committing
a game check I believe you know he said
he's willing to to go on you know right
along with Cleveland Police he's
apologized to everyone and he's going to
work within the community I think it's
redeemable okay and defensively how good
can this team be the young and they're
going to need a lot of these guys to you
know to really step off and and show
that that they can over achieve this
year there's three amigos who were
drafted last year nate orchard Danny
Shelton and Xavier Cooper they really
want to say
you know what let's put ourselves on the
NFL map they're going to need guys like
that to step up because it's going to be
young and they will have growing pains
ochocinco they're coming back where in
the world is Chad Ochocinco that's a
good question I talked to him the other
day he said he was coming back he said
he's going to stay he's going to be a
huge accident Erin and jet he will have
to pry him out of there he didn't show
up yesterday you know we're still kind
of waiting for for the next word from
Chandra but Hugh has no hair to be in
Mary Kay and I can say such things i can
say such things you know that's true ok
so lastly what to expect I know that
everybody is in believe land now and
feeling it for good reason what what to
expect from the Browns this year well
the tough thing for them is they start
five of their first seven games on the
road but two home games are the Ravens
and Tom Brady coming off of his
four-game suspension so that's how they
start out in the first seven games a lot
will be determined by whether or not
they can win on the road early on but
because of that I'm not putting them at
more than five or six victories this
year mary kay thanks for the time
appreciate it we'll see you we'll see
you down the road sounds good my
pleasure you got it mary kay cabot here
on the rich eisen show the rich eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience